it's about time to take your great idea
and turn it into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project are
you trying to showcase your work or sell
products of any kind well you can use
their beautiful templates and customize
just about anything and make a beautiful
website all by yourself and if you get
stuck they have 24/7 award-winning
customer support that is there to help
go to squarespace.com slash Grace for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain too deep we're back with
another episode of not too deep I'm your
host grace Helbig today Kelsey Darragh
is back I don't even know if I'm saying
her last name correctly but that doesn't
matter
it's Kelsey she's back and she's bold
and she's beautiful and she's wonderful
she's been up to so much since the last
time she was here two years ago I
learned about you know she's been in in
Aspen she's been on private jets
she's been relaunching her podcast
getting into deep issues around women
things she's also been going to some sex
parties and I learned all about it and
she came here directly after getting a
root canal so she is the definition of
thriving on this episode of not too deep
with Kelsey Darragh you love the Real
Housewife I do I do love them I didn't
watch the newest Jersey episode last
night so I big plans tonight
she's busy lady massive do you watch
really TV I do not I'm a teen mom
serious car really still oh my god still
it's like growing up with that really
grew up with that high that's the one I
never got into because it felt too much
like my peers oh the I guess housewives
seemed like upper echelon trash yeah but
it felt like older women
being terrible and like something to
aspire to
right
and I felt like the girls getting
pregnant I was like oh no they're too
young to have this situation but now
they've all liked me Millions
yeah fine they're yeah they're making TV
stuff yeah they're fine I'm not worried
about anything I'm worried about me
yeah baby I'm losing money with your
babies well okay let's get into it yeah
we're going she's doing I mean talking
about you're not making money you're the
business woman ever I don't know where
you're getting this false information
from I'm getting it from social media
I'm getting it from just everything
you're working on right now I feel like
your husband enough though right I do
have enough out at all to run a small
country I've said yes like maybe I
appear busy
cuz I'm always carrying one of these
coffees sure I'm not you you could I
mean like you you're working on lots of
project you're working on like a variety
of style well I like to keep my fingers
in all Oh be careful your holes hide
your holes because she's got a good the
last time you're on the podcast was like
two years ago
oh what an honor and you were here with
Kate but I feel like in two years so
much for you has like grown developed
change by BuzzFeed yeah by buzz Phi
which is you know something fascinating
because that's like a world where you're
doing a ton of different [ __ ] under this
one umbrella I remember giving it one of
the drunkest I've ever been in my life
yeah hey thinking you were so attractive
in asking Ella being like do you think I
could sleep with grades like no don't
like get that out your head I was like
okay okay never mind second question
should I talk to her about like leaving
busby and I remember I talked to you I
like the drunkest off your shipping and
you were like you gotta just do it you
gotta believe it I was like now I want
to sleep with her more Jace has two
speeds
I will help save everyone from problems
I didn't know they need to be safe from
or I will yell at everyone don't cry in
a corner I must be fun to be your
boyfriend yeah I haven't been drinking
for a while I got sober good
you sober so not sober shops I get dry
January and then I started having like
the SIBO thing and my gut like it's a
little stomach intestinal thing and then
drink a little bit on vacation then feel
good so now back to it and you're like
maybe there's a whole time yeah was the
alcohol I'm connecting some dots and
there seems one giant black hole all
these devastating well how long have you
been sober 200 in something days how's
it been going
it's the best / easiest like life change
I've ever made really wish I would have
done it sooner yeah I mean you know like
with the internet culture your identity
is built around alcohol in a weird way
lately it becomes inherent in your brand
and it's like knowing mesh that it is
difficult to make that separation do you
feel like you're losing a part of
yourself you're like putting to sleep
yeah putting down your fun side
I've arguably gotten more fun yeah I
don't know if maybe we should have some
people okay so maybe not bad that's my
own opinion but no but I think that's
because there is it's so rampant in you
know especially like content creator
culture because every our jobs are so
willy-nilly and all over the place hmm
but I've been listening to this book the
easy way to control alcohol by Alan Carr
he did the smoking yeah easy way yeah
it's fantastic you love it I love it I
highly recommend because it's just like
a much more positive mmm philosophy on
all of it and like how your life is just
gonna get better tell me it so I don't
have to read it it's basically like your
life it's gonna get better it never
helped you to begin with
you were always under the spell of
alcohol Alan Carr's coming for big yeah
it's I know it's a it's fascinating and
he's someone else reads it in the
British accent so it's very soothing
it's all very fun so you look forward to
not having to drink yeah yeah exactly
it's a more desirable thing um but till
you you left BuzzFeed bye bye you're
working on a show on e oh my god yeah
our second season was
to come out like a week ago wait I don't
know don't talk it's no filter yeah and
this is a panel show about dating yeah
it's the first LGBTQ blind dating show
on network television in America which
was really cool cuz it was on e which is
a big network that yeah they were like
we need a loud white lady to fill that
no it's you know it's less of us making
fun of people which i think is white
people like it so much
yeah like oh it's more like we are them
we're with them we've all been there
it's very so what's the premise of the
show six comedians watch blind dates the
producers from this incredible way of
putting two people like a Republican and
a person who like believes in aliens
together and then you just watch that
and we it cuts back and it's very
reminiscent of those old MTV shows like
take my mom or next her yeah yeah yeah I
think that's why people like it that's
so that's fun and cool energy it's not
that you're the dates have already
happened so it's not like you're
coaching these people I sit on a couch
and I eat the dream job and they bring
me start it's a dream job yeah
I'm not sober sober I'm just you're not
drinking you're driving
yeah one step at a time so this is
already the first seasons out there yes
we're interested way of our second
season that's so excited has any major
takeaways from watching people on blind
dates um holy [ __ ] great question you
gotta be yourself yeah cuz very slowly
what they do is they liquor him up like
any good reality show and so like you
know ten minutes that you see the
audience sees into the day we're
watching like hours of footage but you
get to see like 10 minutes into the date
how real people become once you get that
activity over with so you guys are
watching the completely unedited version
of the oh that gives me anxiety a little
bit yeah so it's um you get to just see
how people are do you watch the circle
enough yes okay
I avoided it at first because I thought
it was going to make me like
sad about because I have also had like a
weird relationship with social media
right now about like how sometimes it
makes me very inspired and sometimes it
makes me very depressed
hmm and that's probably the problem but
so then I avoided the circle because I
thought it was gonna be like okay I want
to see this and then I watched an
episode I was like and this is all I'm
watching and yeah the end yeah okay so
it's it's a bit like that and where you
get to see the raw moments of people
like how they react to a text versus
what they write back in like it's just a
psychology experiment and I think that's
fine yeah have you been on blind dates
before Oh me either my friends know me
too well
I would somehow find right like no
[ __ ] way
especially when you have a little slower
I mean I'm like a microscope compared to
you but like no [ __ ] way could you
blind date know especially because you
assume that they're gonna Google
anything cuz a normal person would
Google I would Google if I was set up on
a blind date with someone what pops up
when you google you just too much it's
all just like you know the thumbnails
from dumb videos and it just looks like
a lot yeah and I like to think that I'm
a much lower key person in you person
but like when if you were to just take
the landscape of Google search it looks
like in them nah it looks like a parody
of like an Internet girl okay you're one
you're coming here from getting a root
canal which is not like a euphemism
that's like for real what just happened
before yeah my mouth is very much and -
you're coming from also Sundance oh yeah
I went to my first Sunday how was that
I've never been before oh my god so I
gotta go as an alumni because I got in
as a writer
last year we congratulations yeah I said
that because I wanted praise boy and the
applications are just open so if anyone
wants to become a writer go play and so
part of the program is you get a free
ticket
cool you ever been no it's beautiful and
fun reputable and just like drunk very
powerful and movie executive
because the altitude I hear everyone's
just like shit-faced the whole time so
nice like Hollywood Scout or rotation
for being so mean but when you're in
that environment and everything's free
and all food is free and you're watching
good films yeah the ones just mood is
different you're like oh is this how I
would be if I didn't live in LA right is
what life is like outside yeah you're
like rubbing elbows with just like Issa
Rae and like an eva longoria and you're
you guys also took a private jet there
oh my god okay what is Lissa Tori that
was such a ballast to a thing called
summit which I wonder if you know some
in LA it's like a I think I get the
emails all the time yeah you're gonna
see loser
no I you went on a private jet I think I
get the emails of like here's we're
having an event if you want to come okay
well here's the thing
all the people that are involved in
summit are very wealthy okay like you
know maybe that was like are you single
you're selling a relation right like you
maybe shouldn't because my situation but
you get to meet just like the coolest
wealthiest people who are like actually
changing the world right people in
charge of I don't know what's an
important thing tables there's so many
people we were like you do what and then
they're like what are you doing I'm like
I talked about
[Laughter]
Loree short i carbon offset all my
flights just so we know but a friend of
a friend of a friend of whatever my
boyfriend's in it I'm not I just was
like tagging along okay they were going
out on their jet and it was like duh you
go on the J yeah the world is burning
literally yeah but on a PJ baby you
gotta go on a PJ no that's not asking
this one's saying I feel like a lot of
people my ether have recently been on
PJ's so it's getting closer to me like
the opportunity has it but you you're
like me I'm assuming in that you don't
like to leave your house often exactly
you gotta leave your house if you want
to be on a PJ that's the one thing
that's stopping me my house and pick me
up
and then I'll take your first thing yeah
I did it really [ __ ] spoils you thing
too is that I feel like it is so
spoiling that knowing that that level
exists is like Chris weird you're
[ __ ] gross out with yourself yeah
this [ __ ] water and there's [ __ ]
sushi on the plane and Cher's like no
one's gonna give me [ __ ] for bringing my
dog or putting my feet on Leo this is
stupid
there's nobody yeah but do it highly
recommend like for sure absolutely try
one this wasn't to Sundance no this was
to summit summit in the same place okay
back-to-back weekends Wow
maybe I'm busy yeah that ice is what I'm
telling you maybe you've been so busy
you don't have time to realize how busy
you I still get tired really fast okay I
thought if I'm too busy where I'm tired
at night where my hand falls asleep in
between my legs
I'm like that were you wake up you're
like oh I am NOT
dad and if you freak out for like a half
a second like will it ever go back or am
I gonna tell me all the way I lost my
arm was I just loved myself too much
yeah hey listen what happens yeah Wow
but you have been busy I haven't gotten
the flu which is usually like telltale
sign that you're too busy yeah for sure
I just I'm working from home so I I see
my foster dog in my partner no yeah okay
so berry ah
berry berry the foster dog my boy berry
okay so for I the idea of foster your
dog makes me nervous because if you form
an emotional attachment what is the plan
you just keep calling them your foster
dog partner and roommate allow you to
keep them know so here's how it went in
was like I was getting the itch uh-huh
for a dog oh yes I don't have to travel
as much anymore right and I was like oh
I'm gonna get this money there's scratch
by going to volunteer so super involved
in the volunteer program will go like
early on Saturdays because when you're
sober and you don't have hangovers you
just wake up early and to do activities
yeah what do I do with all this time
yeah and my hand was going really I went
to volunteer did you walk dogs with my
hand on their leash right that is
attached to their necks yes and we
started with cats fostering cats where
those go like cats are cats are getting
adopted that's a concocted laughing
right dogs are a much higher return rate
the shelter work has 200 dogs as opposed
to the usual like 50 to 60 at most
shelters so it's like Guantanamo Bay
yeah yeah there's [ __ ] brain water and
pigeon [ __ ] and their cages and you're
like oh I'm I'm thinking this is gonna
be sad yeah but in a way like one small
thing right like if a dog starts to
sniff you who growl at you before you're
like
it's incredible it made more improvement
than like any antidepressant ever did in
my life and so I kept going back every
week to just see these small little
incremental changes and then I had the
cats at home well when I passed Barry oh
and his cage
it was just like couldn't keep walking
yeah I never have felt a bond like that
not even to my humans Wow my human
friend I just was like I'm taking him
today
oh I had also had some dental work done
Matt takis I was on valium mark major
moments in your life was this before
after some dental surgery I was on
valium and my friend was like are you
sure you're not just me yeah and he's
been with us since Thanksgiving he's
done some trial runs of being at other
people's houses to see if they wanted to
adopt him but you should know dogs are
no joke that's I know they're no joke
and I wasn't I didn't do the slow like I
tell everyone like take your time like
what you're doing like really like test
it out make sure because you can think
through what a dog needs but until you
actually like have one it's like the
most challenges blood [ __ ] coming out of
their ass sudden they step in a [ __ ]
ant pile and they can't use words to
tell you where they've been or what
they've been doing what is oh like six
years yeah adult but she's an adult so
now like things on her body are like
aching and like she has a limp like
right now because she like got too
excited and like jumped at the mailman
but like I'm like is it like did you
dislocate a bones I was go were scared
is it just a tweak and you're fine
tomorrow so but it's a lot yeah but I
also can't reconcile like the adopting
of a dog then falling in love and then
not being able because I think I would
have just had to have the dog if I
adopted or if I had one I'd be an
adoption nurse amazing cats were like
bye
but yeah there is something about a
connection with a dog because I feel
like they are so much dirtier than cat
and you're like oh you can see inside of
my soul yeah but I think very special
and I always said like I still am okay
with someone adopting him as long as
they will love him more than I do which
is impossible so I'm keeping no problem
how does that work then do peep is he
star like available on their website
yeah people can come in like uh-huh yeah
and like my goal was to use social media
help yeah get these animals out and so
I've had people DM me or Facebook groups
are so many la like rescue Facebook
conscious as you should know like you do
not adopt a dog from the [ __ ] breeder
no no no that's taboo you run out of
town yeah yeah and so you'll run out of
town yeah so yeah tons of Facebook
groups and you just gotta get a real sob
story going yeah mm-hmm like Barry
couldn't see out of his eye when we
bought him and people were just like I
want to help when he's better and can
see and this is already fixed so is the
plan to eventually slowly keep bearing
or is the plan keep the door open
but listen in a ideal world my boyfriend
I would break up he would want the dog
and I would want the dog and then we
would split the dog oh and then that way
I could still do a bunch of stuff and
travel and I have to worry about it but
it's not I think just my responsibility
right now he's like fully Myers mom my
roommates and my boyfriend are like you
did this it's your dog like a kid yeah
yeah I'm like yeah and I get up at 6:00
or every buck and welcome to I sit I
take care of this thing well Barry I
mean one it's just great for social
media beautiful photos because she looks
a little she's a little she got boxed
her face she's got like a pitbull I'm an
English bulldog body I just did it's
still sitting in my car have to mail it
off the swab to see her DNA
we thought Barry was a boxer what is he
he was he is English bulldog and
ciaochao ciaochao ciaochao that's nuts
cuz I thought I was like berry and goose
have similarities to me yeah black hole
the bull head yeah just like a wrecking
ball when that thing comes at you in the
morning [ __ ] look out it's good sleep
with you um when my boyfriend's out of
town yes but when he's in town no great
she no she sleeps in I called it she's
got a closet will my closet it's like
right next to the bed yeah and I say
it's gooses room so I just have a bed in
there and she just likes being like
surrounded by clothes like in there
she's a cutie okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back more
questions for kausi on not too deep I
bet you have a great idea that you'd
like to turn into a reality well you can
with Squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
you want to start a new business
showcase work publish content sell
products or more Squarespace is the tool
for you they have beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks so you can make a
beautiful website all by yourself they
also have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you can get the help you need with
their 24/7 award-winning customer
support they empower millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real
head to squarespace.com slash grace for
a free trial when you're ready to lunch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that squarespace.com slash Grace
offer code grace would you buy a t-shirt
for $50 if you knew it only cost seven
dollars to make probably not I know I
wouldn't but with ever Lane you never
overpay for quality clothes
make premium essentials using the finest
materials without traditional markups
they want you to know what you're paying
for and why so they tell you their real
costs and a radically transparent about
every step in their process from the
materials they use to the ethical
factories they work with no matter your
style or preference ever Elaine's
clothes look better that cost less they
last longer they sell directly to you so
their prices are 30 to 50 percent lower
than traditional retailers they have
essentials like a cotton crew t-shirt
that are exactly what they should be
very versatile very simple very stylish
and made from quality materials and
right now you can check out our
personalized collection at everland comm
slash grace and you'll get free shipping
on your first order that's ever Lane
comm slash grace every Lane comm slash
grace confidently and secure your
podcast is back took a hiatus for a
little bit we took a week off okay what
over the holidays - like revamp and
start season - yeah and it feels like
it's taken a very whole course like
you've been very raw and vulnerable oh
my god adult [ __ ] was all about bit like
this like not too deep servicing and
then like dipping our toes in serious
and then you come right back because
it's like that's not who we over funny
silly girl yeah and then I realized when
I'm alone in my apartment on my couch
mm-hmm it's like therapy I can't help it
yeah and I think with like also the way
the world has kind of changed sense
adult [ __ ] totally really hard to be
like lol like yeah you're like oh my god
I'm so depressed about the State of the
Union especially when it's like your job
is communicating kind of what you're
going through and like your point of
view on it yeah do you feel like nervous
about how vulnerable you've been and how
much you've explored on there or is it
more exciting to be like I'm just
putting it all out there like I guess
it's the same feeling as when you work
for the internet like I don't know maybe
you can relate when you're in your home
in front of your camera and you have
full control yeah you just talk yeah you
don't realize
that in my case thousands in your case
millions of people are gonna be watching
and you're like oh [ __ ] and then once
it's out there you don't realize like it
doesn't feel as weighted sure you know
news stories aren't picking it up and
[ __ ] like that like it for me it's just
the listeners have become my support
system in my therapist's oh don't worry
yeah it's so like just a breath of fresh
air it just feels like yeah especially
like as you get older I've found that I
give less of a [ __ ] about like having so
many walls um I mean here and there like
sharing what I want to and being in
control of like how much I put out there
is still something that I subscribe to
but I I want to hear more personal
stories like people that are my peers so
why am I not sharing personal story
exactly what's like your deepest secret
you've kept without putting on the
Internet it's coming but there because I
know you put out an episode recently
about being in an abusive relationship
div and I know that you talked about
like how like the unexpected emotions
and rollercoaster of like should I
shouldn't how do I yeah how do you feel
after its release now holy [ __ ] I I mean
like you guys know me listeners and and
in the room like I am NOT a shy person I
don't really get nervous I'm putting it
all out there regret it later
yeah but for weeks I was getting like
stomachaches
you had known that you were gonna do
this or wanted to do this and the
morning I was supposed to record I just
got like sweaty I was sweating my own
house
and I was like what the [ __ ] is this and
I realized that that was the abuse
coming back that was like the
manipulation hadn't left my body even
though it had been so many years later
that I was still terrified of some
consequence happening to me and I'm like
who where what nothing's happening but
it was definitely programmed so deeply
programmed and that was the first time
that I was like okay you're really
taking a risk and I tell you what the
second
I accidentally released it too early and
I really feel like a day too early on
YouTube as soon as I started seeing the
comments come in I was like a hundred
million percent I was the universe made
it was made for me to do this really
about it I mean it's so great a single
negative comment have I come across Wow
not a single story that hasn't been in
some way inspiring for me to learn from
someone else it's unfortunately such a
common thing and I think we as strong
women especially are afraid to admit
that we were I'm making quotes like one
of those girls use that the
embarrassment and shame around it is
debilitating yeah and to be able to rise
above that and say no I'm I'm surviving
the healing because I survived the
trauma that makes me badass yeah that's
like you know I think we as women don't
want to sound as complaining or dramatic
especially because it's like why is it
that bad how's he questioning like did I
really go through right and it wasn't
till you know many years later that I
saw
oh [ __ ] like yeah I should have been
like I should be way more [ __ ] up
because I applaud anyone that's you know
can do I think it out whatever way they
have to but yeah it's like something
like that where I'm sitting on my couch
right and I'm able to talk about it and
also laugh and make jokes about it that
made me feel like this is my purpose
like yeah you turned pain into purpose
total Jay kind of what we do anyways on
the internet were like a he'll laugh at
me so you're like here's a space it's
okay and also just helpful I think for
so many people to like you said they
don't realize what they're in and then
they go oh this is identical to what
yeah I am going through its normal like
we heard you know in that situation and
love is such a strong feeling yeah
taught to like stick by someone and help
each other through something and love is
the most powerful feeling at all and
it's like no like yeah abuse is kind of
like more strong of a feeling just so
hopeful and yeah it's one of those
things where you just it's hard to admit
to yourself so how can you admit it to
like your family or your friends or the
police or whatever
so it's about getting over that idea and
I think like they're still a huge
problem with like boys weren't toxic
masculinity men like that's what I think
the main issue is totally gotta teach
men how to not abuse women instead of
teaching women how to come forward about
their abuse but it called me crazy sip
coffee sips coffee zips coffee no but I
think that's really cool on a testament
I think where you're headed in like
creative endeavors you know like keeping
it light but also going deep enough and
like using your personal stories kind of
human all along the way right is there
stuff coming up that you're excited
about
oh my god I released my first book this
year you know many bugs yeah but I was
gonna ask for you like this seems like
the logical right yeah you have so many
stories and so much like my perspective
and experience growing up in public
school Florida know that you know so
we've got that coming out it's called
dumb [ __ ] panic and it's a workbook
like a comedy workbook about panic and
anxieties where they're awesome
yeah and then we're gonna start live
touring for confidently insecure which
I'm really nervous about because how do
you feel a theatre grace yeah when you
find out let me know Mary and I are
doing some live shows and it is more
difficult than it used to dude but you
guys tour we we went on a small tour
last summer but when we used to like
four years ago it was before anyone was
really like touring sighs it's like any
bad yeah and so it was a more novel
thing now it's just like everybody's
yeah what's like the capacity you try
and book a theater out like a hundred
see - Wow
sometimes they're like nah you guys can
feel for like now we can't see where I'm
at I'm like I think they're starting out
with two and I was there can we try 15
yeah
can we try like a club like even a
teahouse industry let's try 50 we do a
dance studio
I'm nervous we're doing an international
show in London it's really cool I think
that's what I'm excited about
that sounds very excited yeah I'm also
Florence Pugh oh how do you say her last
name puh puh puh puh puh they kind of
whisper like the sound that you make
really see her good tell me she's not I
don't know much about her other than
you're obsessed midsummer I didn't see
it I know I just saw a parasite the
other night you just saw look what do
you I'm watching a lot of reality TV I'm
very booked and busy a lot of shows love
after a lot I love after what's gonna
watch itself just started watching that
oh I started at like Susan 1 which I
feel like it's a mistake as you fall in
love and then they change well I started
season 2 I think thinking it was Susan
wine it's different people different
people done there's life after lockup Oh
so get ready to have your days taken
away from you because you get in love
what's their story and then they show
you the after they're after story
involved with their life and then guess
what it doesn't go as planned it feels
less scripted than a lot of reality TV
it feels like it is because it's like
Jill's anafi I can't believe that they
get to film as much as they get to film
for that show so I'm like how are they
allowed to just like be on the premises
watching like them we need to have a
reality TV award show can you get on
there has to be one right hour I mean I
would love to play no usually there's
drew Hazlehurst or whatever his name is
start much going on so I'll for sure
eyes you also a midst and amongst all of
these cool things I'm obsessed with your
makeup tutorials on Instagram I'm so
glad you brought that up because I did
my makeup
hi-yah I looked in the mirror a lot
tonight wait green [ __ ] cream but I
feel I like them because you do
experiment with so many colors yeah and
I truly have no idea what you're about
to do you are what we call a natural
beauty like that's just what she looks
like right there I like to transport a
bit of a drag queen in that I love it
because I'm so intimidated by my eyes
shadow colors especially I can be like
you know confident in like I'm gonna try
something crazy and I'm like Browns
every girls like schedule is like go
crazy and spend like $30 on a crazy
color yeah never wear it yes you don't
know how to apply it and stick with your
like 14 year old yeah to face naked
chocolate
yep bronzer palette that you've had four
since high school I was also too afraid
of color yes and what I found happens
and what helps is if you don't look at
what you're wearing so in most videos
I'll be wearing a robe that's and my
hair back because the second you get
other colors involved you're like do
your influence yeah and it just might
not match so I start with makeup first
and it's really meditative and I love
those videos like I'm a fan of to make
oh yeah know what I saw you were doing
them I was like this is so fun because
they show them a explore page all the
time but I don't follow anyone yes'm and
they always just seem like a little too
far out of reach for like something I
would try even if I did feel really bold
one write on a colorful lip no but I was
like okay she's doing these are fun and
this isn't a joke she's like doing it
well let me tell you why I've been in
all industries of the internet and
you're none more harsh really I'm cruel
I was gonna ask what is it like not
putting it up in that world so I call it
not a guru because I don't think I'm
Niki tutorials you're like chocolate
like I'm not trying to be in that world
because it just seems like it's too much
existed
but thirteen-year-old girls will have no
[ __ ] problem dragging you straight to
hell I mean they are me why don't you
post them on YouTube I'm like I'm okay
I'm okay where I could comment moderate
my engine yeah Wow I didn't now I'm
curious supposed to unjust oh you sure
to elicit the comments but absolutely
chef when did the like when was the
thing that pushed you over into posting
them let's see when I was 15 I would
lock myself in my mom's bathroom and say
you're not leaving until you're pretty
like why is it Chanel makeup and so I've
always been super interested in the way
makeup can transform yeah and again I
think it wasn't until I left BuzzFeed
started working from home I had an asset
of time and an asset of PR boxes that it
was like that's why was I want the PR
boxes you should have the PR but I I got
like one a while ago like a year ago and
I feel like they're like herself yeah we
want her to what young girls to
transform but home you had time you had
the resources and I was like write a
script would be with me get and the
answer would be we make up and so it's
been just like a minute it really is
meditative yeah I blast whatever [ __ ]
Spotify playlist is on and then I just
know what I'm doing do you edit them
yourself they say yeah do you edit them
on your phone Wow no no because I've
heard of people that yeah that I'm like
how do you been edit on your phone I
don't even know how to edit these kinds
of things
oh you just a speed ramp and premiere oh
do you have it any of your videos I do I
add it all in Final Cut Pro so I have
been told to learn premier wait you edit
all your videos for the most part
probably like 90% of them [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay Kylie I'm just because I have
the times and I also am very insecure
about the shooting process of like there
are times when I'm just like sitting
there Fred many mauvais yeah Oh am i
working through a joke and it's just
very embarrassing and even though I have
this girl in Roseann whose hydros and
you're wonderful and I know she wouldn't
judge a second of me for sending her
that raw footage I just feel like yeah
but we can expect continuous mandatory I
got one I got one come out with call
girls vegan line tomorrow have you been
approached by these makeup companies now
the only one I mean I got sent on while
I was like did you yeah I am fascinated
by these but here's the thing they
specifically told me and Lily uh-huh
that we got invited because we were like
if you thought we just want to remind
you before we get started that your
cafeteria table is very like we've been
getting too much [ __ ] for only invited
in so we thought we'd throw some regular
gals in the mix we give this dude trash
he did some time on this weird island
but my god we have any glitter like arts
and crafts corner we keep them busy yeah
so I went on one of those like in woods
or a trips before its time on like a
couple of their like OPR things but then
the only one that has reached out to me
being like we saw your tutorial wise
covergirl oh shut up I guess I guess
shout out to covergirl yeah that's
awesome yeah so I don't see them doing a
ton obviously Tarte
drugstore makeup right considered right
yeah yeah then they got that uh Lily
Reinhardt
oh he's Borg yes Hague made her the face
she's like she's bringing it back gotcha
hmm
I saw that you posted your skeleton
x-rays uh-huh on Twitter what was that
like Oh Victor Bakke body but like my
vagina bone I found it in my medical
records instead of my desktop for like a
week boy I was like don't know
apparently I have pee in my bladder in
that x-ray that you can see Wow get
people medically like trying to diagnose
things someone told me I'd scoliosis and
I was like you [ __ ] stay in your
corner I don't know why I pushed it I
don't know why also how did I get that I
I think it's great because a year I mean
I feel like I've moved away from using
Twitter as soon as freely as I used to
use it and I feel like you're still like
putting up whenever you want them like I
admire that it's gonna come back to
fight I love it because this is what
Twitter was and what I love so much
about it now I'm just like wow
everything feels like people are just
like dogs on leashes ready to like
attack metaphor they're all good dogs
they're all good dog because no bad dogs
here okay we're gonna take one last
break when we go back we have Twitter
questions for you get that ad money
grace yeah we need space you've a bunch
of stuff lying around the house that you
just don't use like a kids baseball
glove that doesn't fit hopefully you
have kids that at one point used that
glove a pair of jeans that you only wear
one time or an old phone hiding in a
drawer somewhere well there's an app you
can use to sell this stuff it's called
Macari it's a selling app that makes it
fast and easy to sell almost anything it
couldn't be simpler you take a few
pictures of your stuff you add a
description and boom your item is listed
once it's sold Mercury emails you a
shipping label and you just stick it off
and send it
no meetups no hassles my favorite thing
you don't have to meet people in person
with millions of people using the
Macario app in all 50 states
stuff really sells the app has over
500,000 reviews on the App Store with an
average 4.8 star rating so why not give
it a try don't let that stuff you don't
use go to waste
sell it ship it and get paid with Merc
re you can find Macari on the App Store
or on mer CARICOM that's em er CA r I
Merc re the selling app okay Kelsey yeah
I've been two years since I've asked you
the two questions ask every single guest
that's on the podcast I remember one so
I remember both perhaps your answers
have changed let's find out who alive or
dead would you most like to throw cold
spaghetti at my aunt Vicky I've never
said that publicly and I'd like to use
this public airspace time [ __ ] you Vicky
you're bad you're bad family remember
nobody likes you
Wow I was gonna call in line Vicky
calling me like Vicky rebuttal I was
trying to be a photographer when I was a
kid I had a camera I was going around
Thanksgiving taking pictures of people
and my little cousin kept jumping in
front of it her daughter was like no
[ __ ] I didn't say that but I was like
no trying to take pictures of and aunt
Vicky yelled at me I won't take a
picture of her [ __ ] kid and you know
I look business now yeah okay with our
second kid okay tell us your worst pants
shooting story or close call but only
use three words or three small phrases
okay I think last time I was here I said
sushi in 101 jean jacket so since that
okay thank you so uh sushi okay a word
room Oh No
excavation is goofy I don't know if
that's the right word excavation
evacuation the excavation we had we had
to clear a space needed to be clear yes
they might have taken it down by
bulldozer I'm not sure that happen oh
that's amazing
um okay let's get into some Twitter
questions for you yeah
Robby wants to know have you attended
any more sex parties yes Thank You Robby
okay in my pockets we talked a lot about
my open relationship and part of that is
the fun of being able to try and
discover how to have sex with other
people
okay and one of those ways is going to
sex parties which I always thought were
like very like Eyes Wide Shut sexy sure
that they are but there's a lot more
stuff going on talked about and yes I
have been and this one was in a big
spooky mansion okay and that's where I
would assume they all like yeah no and
there it was a Halloween sex party okay
and one of the themes of the room was
like torture the next thing in the room
was like haunted closet room was
bloodbath okay I feel like I would go
through to only two emotions of laughing
and horror yeah yeah it's about right
okay you should go you should go if not
just say man yeah yeah it really is like
half the people are there just really
what the [ __ ] is going on and then there
are people who are seriously they're
like yeah but you should go just so like
just I'm sure the social dynamic of it
yeah it's whole new world it is
fascinating
some was no best movie or TV show to
watch hi well I don't smoke weed so I'm
gonna go with high on valium okay she's
my weed you talk I do yeah and it's
wonderful I'm happy for you what's your
favorite hi shel I did watch married at
first sight last night high and high was
just like this I watched it forever but
last night I was like this shows crazy
they have to live together for two
months and they just met each other fair
yeah the actual reality of the show hit
me pretty hard I would say the shot it's
not a show I would say I've never had so
many incredible thoughts while getting a
root canal today oh my god I like cured
cancer in my brain I wrote like 75
Twitter jokes at one point I like had
them stopped and I took like the plastic
out of my mouth and I was like can you
write down that I need to make a
chapstick and I'm like oh yeah shibez
galore and then they put some sort of
down little bit hopefully you dental dam
over your face like what you think
lesbians use for sex with you yeah they
don't they put a dental dam over your
tooth and they tell you it so that you
don't get like any stuff in other areas
of your mouth and okay they're just
trying to isolate the toothpaste okay so
yeah they dental dam your mouth shut Wow
and then how long does it take like an
hour Wow
so you're just sitting there with your
eyes open for I don't know I'm high as a
[ __ ] high I got my ear pods in
I'm holding my boyfriend's hand and he's
DJing for me like I sort of guy came up
with so many Twitter jokes and I was
like don't forget it don't forget it
second he turn off laughing gasps oh my
god I'll get a root canal don't you know
but that'll make I think I would rather
get a root canal than go to a sex party
who is your dream guest for your podcast
Dead or Alive oh I haven't thought about
that or alive Wow I mean who [ __ ] ski
[ __ ] so much pressure I'm dead I guess
okay I'll go with alive I think maybe
like Elizabeth Warren would be cool
right now
really old voice microphone have a good
she does anything interesting you say
but more so I want to hear her voice on
a mic yeah and then dead I guess I don't
know who do you want on here that's dead
oh wow I don't know I don't know who I
choose
I'd be like anyone that wants to oh yeah
well even he probably might have some
curious thing I mean I would hear his
pants [ __ ] story I think it is I
mean I don't want to know because it's
probably too dark and awful just answer
the story itself okay here's a question
someone Brooke wants to know what do
people need to know about fostering dogs
oh gosh patience patience and more
patience really I am the least patient
person in my boyfriend's the most
patient person and we got a foster dog
it was like he couldn't even hear the
dog breed without getting upset and like
I became this soothing like oh my baby
come you have so much [ __ ] patience
because they're so cute and it takes
three months for a dog's true
personality to come out once you switch
them in homes and that goes the same for
a doggy pad for years if you move them
to a new location interesting the guard
doesn't come down for three months so
know that the dog you get at the shelter
good or bad may or may not be the dog
may be a little different yeah and I
think usually it's a good thing is so
glad to be loved yeah yeah yeah no that
makes a lot of sense also just I would
assume preparing yourself for anything
because you don't you can kind of know
their medical history but you really
won't know like you said with their
personality three months like I have you
gotta have a little bit of money I'm not
gonna lie yeah those shelters will give
you free food if you're fostering okay
mine didn't start busy but you gotta
have a little mini yeah
take medical stuff for dogs is not GE
get insurance was there a mystery
[ __ ] at the holidays this year I'm so
glad whoever did this I told the story
about in my family I have 52 first
cousins so I have a lot of family who
every year for the holidays we'd get
together and we would have things like
mini raves or like drum circle it was
always big a huge party hashtag Florida
yeah every year someone would leave a
giant [ __ ] on the toilet see on on the
Twizy and we would call it the Phantom
pooper because we could never yeah it
started as like a joke and then every
year it would happen and it would be
like we were waiting for the moment of
like who's gonna discover the Phantom
poop this year and like we would oh my
god fights what happened if like who was
it would have like deep investigative
like serial Cyril mysteries of like who
who do we think it is and like people
would take sides and like just when you
think we'd get there a holiday without
it it would be like the last day this
could span over day Oh a week we'd be
going to my grandpa's house my uncle's
house my mom's house my sister's play
it's like you never knew it was gonna
happen and like by process of
elimination we were always trying to
guess who yeah in the family and I think
I know who it is you think it's the same
person every year and that's the trick
right great is you think you know and
then one year you're like that person
wasn't here or like right you know this
[ __ ] looks oddly baby-sized to this year
was it a small cousin that's been
getting us all and so this holiday we
did not have the big gathering but we
normally yeah so you know there was no
random poober Wow this year but stay
tuned because I think we're all gonna
get together for Burning Man potentially
so there might be a mid August I will
absolutely
oh wow that's the most Florida story
yeah Missouri I mean still trash what
that's amazing okay on the opposite end
of that someone wants to know what's
your go-to self-care activity mass
rating it releases serotonin and it gets
you a good mood and it can really take
away a panic attack an impending a panic
attack if you feel one coming all right
that's right to the poor boy and what
celebrities do you want in a
professional game of tag oh [ __ ]
obviously like Usain Bolt right it's
impossible to win in that situation yeah
so definitely him maybe like
I don't know who else is good it's
scheming and getting out of things from
we don't say [ __ ] name on the five
guys though I would like Donald Trump
and Hussein bolt in a game of tagging
Hussein boat just gets taken down trying
the tag Usain Bolt would be a lovely
thing to watch and a point in loud
alright that's my game opinion on sloths
cute or creepy oh my god
creepy yeah I'm not a slots person I
they move too slow that I think they're
scheming something or that is Liars it's
that slow build in like a horror film
before something happens but that's just
their normal resting yeah their vibe is
anticipate ory I don't like it no and I
bet you their hairs are really a lot
thicker than people are think yeah yeah
yeah yeah they look it looks course yeah
someone's no are you and Jared still
looking for a girlfriend sure hit me on
the DM yeah and they always don't live
here don't [ __ ] hit me up in this
area major metropolis city that I'm
visiting often London New York Miami
period my role she has spoken and then a
couple people asked cheese question mark
hmm yes is this a thing in your world no
but someone wants to know Matthew
Francis who looks like he's doing a chef
coat in a photo about her favorite
restaurants in La oh austrial Ibuka
which has the best pasta in los angeles
come [ __ ] fight me I dare you Wow
come fight me grace really and if you
can la antica off Sunset has the best
Italian Nia potent Napoleon pizza nice
that's it that's awesome okay Kelsey
we're reaching the end of the podcast
yeah
I mean much fun it's so much fun and I'm
gonna come on you're hot yeah and it's
gonna be a great time we're gonna get
deep
yeah the opposite of not teeth I'm ready
mask of eight I hope not in my life
where what are you up to next like
what's in the near future for people uh
buy tickets to whatever these live shows
we're gonna end now please there you go
I'm okay before you leave
every guess that's on the podcast is a
personalized fortune cookie this one is
a little bit more wider oh yeah this is
your one shot to plea to Florence and
Zac consider having an open relationship
like yours first of all wait is she
dating Zach Braff which what the [ __ ] oh
really I did yeah cuz he's got a baby
face yes I said Florence this is your
time to don't be fooled by his baby face
is foggy hope I know you're like British
or something but you guys are there get
out and come to eight six yeah no that's
my plea is he's your dad yeah that's a
horror film I mean yeah she can slide
into your DMS oh she doesn't have some
you know that's how close she is oh god
yeah did you hate people like better I
don't know that they're like they're
different they're living a better life
yeah healthier they're detached yeah
they're free they're artistes yeah
especially people that are doing actual
art that don't have social media I'm
like yeah that's a life that's a life
anyway guys go check out Kelsey listen
to the podcast check out all of her
makeup videos boy look at the Instagram
for burial
Oh God the bear exam daily bury our
story Taylor thank you and thank you for
coming back oh my god and I'll see you
in two years
yes perfect we'll schedule it now we'll
see you guys next time when I'm episode
not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep
2deep was Christ back not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]